[موسيقى]
كل ما يتطلبه الأمر هو لمحة
وربحت براغ ، فأنا مدمن
مغرم بمشهد من
بئر خرافية هناك قلعة تهيمن
على الأفق بعد كل
الشوارع المرصوفة بالحصى الساحرة
، مدينة تتناسب معًا مثل نظرة بانورامية
هذا براغ هو
لغز يغريني بالعودة للاستكشاف والفهم ، لقد
وصلت إلى براغ مليئة
بالرهبة والإثارة التي لم تستطع النظر فقط
إلى مدينة
يتضمن تاريخها الحديث أحداثًا مجيدة
مثل الثورة المخملية قبل 31 عامًا ،
لقد كنت أفكر في العديد من  مرات
ولم
أفهم حقًا أنه حان الوقت
لتصحيح ذلك ،
أعلم أن زيارتي هذه المرة ستكون
مختلفة
في هذه الأوقات غير المؤكدة ،
سأبدأ بتثبيت نفسي
في معلم مألوف كان
ثابتًا على الصخور لمدة
ستة قرون ، جسر تشارلز ،
جسر البرج في لندن  البوابة الذهبية
في سان فرانسيسكو
، جسر بروكلين في
نيويورك ، يمكن لجسر تشارلز في براغ أن يصمد
أمامهم جميعًا
وهناك صوت
لن تسمعه  في أي مكان آخر
تلك الضحكة التي يمكن سماعها
بطول جسر تشارلز
زادينيك بيرجمان ،
لن تتجاهل
أو تنسى عندما نجلس مع أصدقائي
في حانة ونشرب البيرة أصدقائنا من
المباني الأخرى ، فأنت تعلم أن شققنا
قادمة لأنهم يعرفون ذلك  نحن
هناك ،
لسنا بحاجة إلى شبكة داخلية كما
تعرفها وهواتف
نضحك فقط
[ضحك]
هل يمكن أن تتخيل
يومًا مغادرة براغ ، لا يمكنني
العيش في مدن أخرى في مدن أخرى
خارج أماكن أخرى
ممارسة الذهب وبراغ هي قلب
ممارسة أوروبا  مركز أوروبا
يمارس التواصل بين
الجزء الغربي والشرقي من أوروبا من خلال
جسر تشارلز ،
هذه rgs هي أصول
أصلية من القرن الرابع
عشر ،
وهذا ما أدركه
تمامًا مثل جسره المحبوب زيدان
هو كنز محلي
يعد بلمحة  في هذه
المدينة أود أن أريكم وأه أود
تذوق أسماكنا الخاصة
من أسماك النهر هذه من النهر
نعم هل أنت جاد نعم
نهر أه أنا  المياه النظيفة جدًا نظيفة
ويمكننا أن نأكل السمك من هذا
النهر ،
لا
أصدقك وأنا على وشك اكتشاف مدى خطئي
في حشد الدخان الذي يدخن من
النهر
بسكين سمك حقيقي لا تفعله  لا نرى هذه في
راحة
الآن نحن نأكل حتى نتمكن من إزالة
أقنعةنا ،
إنها مدخنة ،
هذا جيد جدًا
، هذه سمكة برية ومفترسة للغاية ،
كانت غاضبة
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
مزحة قديمة ، صديق جديد ، رحلة حقيقية
هتاف لقاء هتاف